sint jan zelezny n'avait jamais songé à
travailler dans un hôpital avant la mi
mars
comme tout le monde j'étais un peu
coincé chez moi avec la pandémie
je me sentais impuissant que j'ai
demandé ben oui ce que vous avez besoin
aussi où sont vos besoins les plus
criants ils m'ont dit des deux nuits de
soirée en zone rouge
ok j'ai coché oui partout en suisse
depuis début mai puis j'aime vraiment ça
la jeune femme qui a travaillé dix ans
comme spécialiste en matériaux de
construction a maintenant d'autres
projets ces projets patients on est tous
dans l'équipe patient vit notre but
c'est que le patient soit maintien est
acquis ou d'améliorer sa condition de
vie de diminuer son anxiété
l'avocate marie mai beaulac est devenue
aide préposés aux bénéficiaires à
l'animé aussi à celle des gens de la
lande g9 une semaine et mon travail
la jeune femme de 29 ans a pris soin de
sa mère avant qu'elles ne meurent du
cancer
pour moi les résultats c'était la mère
de quelqu'un d'autre dans chaque moment
dans le fait de détenir une main dans le
field d'appliquer la crème tendrement
dans les faits d essayer d'avoir des
discutions et rendant les petits gestes
celle qui s'entraîne aussi pour un
ultramarathon apprécie encore plus le
travail des préposés parfaitement c'est
un travail qui tellement exigeant de
déplacer les résidents dans l'île visée
d parfois se soulever de marché pendant
huit heures de temps toute la journée
sur laitages la chaleur avec
l'équipement de protection individuelle
j'ai trouvé ce excessivement c'est les
paysans à 19 ans gabriel courtois a
répondu à l'appel je suis un étudiant
atteint donc j'étudiais le comme tout le
monde la distance à la maison puis
jusqu'à hier par match il pas là
pendant la pandémie je me disais que
chez la personne la mieux placée pour
aller aider
puis ensuite ce qui m'a interpellé mais
je pense que comme tout le monde j'ai vu
qu'il y avait à la mi mai il a commencé
comme aide de service auprès de
convalescents de lakovic 19
il travaille maintenant avec des
patients âgés à la cité de la santé de
laval
la satisfaction de donneurs soit
quelqu'un qui voit en arrière pour le
ciel du nord de l'île de montréal
la plate forme je contribue a permis de
répondre à la crise
ça nous apporte et 1500 embauches en
l'espace de trois mois
en fait c'est ce qu'on fait en une année
complète habituellement les trois quarts
de ces volontaires souhaite rester dans
le réseau de la santé
since et angelo zhi a décidé d'étudier
en soins infirmiers c'est concret on est
vraiment connecté avec le bien qu'on
fait puisque c'est sa maman qui j'en
peux plus
i say and with despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]